y equals 2x minus 1 on x plus 2.
it's a rational function because on the
top and the bottom you've got some
polynomials
and we're going to try and understand
what happens here so remember i said
before we're looking for shape
intercept intercepts i should say if
appropriate asymptotes and also a point
for scale
if it's needed okay now one of the
things that's interesting here which is
different to exponentials and logs like
we looked at yesterday
is that the shape is kind of going to be
defined by where your intercepts and
your asymptotes are so that's where i'm
going to
begin we're going to find x-intercepts
first
and at this point you come like i know
how to do this right
i let y equal 0 and in this case if y
equals 0
i'm going to want the numerator up here
to also be zero
i don't care what the denominator is
there's no value you can put in the
denominator
that makes y equal zero what you need is
for the numerator
to be zero and then once you have the
numerator be zero zero divided by
anything
is zero except for 0. don't divide by 0.
so
to get that value i want 2x minus 1
to equal 0 so i'm going to get 2x
equals 1. so x equals a half
there is my x-intercept same idea with
the y-intercept i'm going to let
x equal 0. so in this case i get y
equals all my x terms are going to
disappear
so this guy here vanishes away this guy
here
vanishes away and you just get left with
minus 1
over 2. done there are my intercepts
so intercepts check now i want to think
about asymptotes so
with my asymptotes i'm expecting there's
going to be a horizontal asymptote
and there may be multiple vertical
asymptotes but in this case we have a
fairly simple graph to begin
so i'm going to think about the vertical
one first remember
from before this is my excuse to look at
ian mckellen again because he's awesome
vertical asymptotes come from domain
discontinuities places where the graph
breaks so in our context with rational
functions
what we're saying is well the
denominator's not allowed to be zero
so find me the place where that happens
and then you're not allowed to go there
okay
so let's have a look here's the
denominator x plus 2
and i'm not allowed to make it 0. so if
i do let it equal 0 what you're going to
find is
this equation right here is the place
you're not allowed to go
this is the vertical asymptote okay
that's it
what about the horizontal asymptote well
i'm going to think about what happens
when you put in really large values of x
both on the positive side
and the negative side now as an example
there's more than one way to do this but
i'm going to just give you the
the simplest way let's just think about
a couple of values like say
x equals a hundred if x were equal to
a hundred what would you get for your y
value like this is a
large value of x i would get y equals
um 200 minus 1. so that's 199
divided by uh 102
102. okay now my calculator is going to
tell me that 199 divided by 102
it's 1.95 that's my calculator tells me
okay
now what if i went bigger if i went to x
equals a thousand what would happen
well why if i go ahead and do the same
substitution it's going to become
two lots of a thousand that's two
thousand take away one
so that's one thousand nine hundred and
ninety nine and then i'm gonna divide by
substitute again one thousand plus two
a thousand and two now when i go reach
for my calculator again
instead of 1.95 which was the previous
value my calculator is now telling me
it's 1.995
okay so i'm approaching something right
1.95
1.995 what am i approaching and the
answer is
i'm clearly approaching 2 and i'm
approaching it from underneath
2 right i'm just beneath 2 and i'll get
closer and closer to that
now you can go ahead and you can test
some large negative values as well
x equals negative 100 or negative a
thousand
i can tell you right now you're also
going to be approaching
2 but you'll approach it from the other
side look i'll just prove it just for
the sake of it let's do it with y equals
a thousand
sorry x equals negative a thousand got
both things wrong there
um when i go ahead and do the
substitution uh negative thousand so
this is negative two thousand minus one
so negative two thousand and one
and then on the denominator what am i
getting negative a thousand plus 2
this is uh 998 right now even without me
evaluating this in the calculator
you can see this is close to 2 but it's
uh
going to be hold on a second what am i
done no there's a minus down the bottom
there
those negatives are going to cancel and
if you okay just for the sake of it
right
you've got 2001 divided by 998
and sure enough you're just going to be
slightly above 2. i've got 2.005
on my calculator okay so therefore i'm
concluding all of this by saying i have
a horizontal asymptote
at y equals two there's my horizontal
asymptote
there's my vertical one okay i'm ready
to put this
onto a cartesian plane now so let's go
ahead and draw one
and make this a bit thicker and i'm just
going to take all those bits and pieces
and add them onto my graphs so
got some arrows here all right what were
we saying so we started with that
intercepts didn't we so we said
intercepts where x
equals a half let's put some spots like
uh
1 and 2 here which made x equals a half
right there
i better label it as well a half and
then i said y
equals negative a half for my
y-intercept so that's going to be if i
call that 1
negative 1 negative 2 it's going to be
about there so this is
negative a half so i've got my
intercepts
and then i also had my vertical
asymptotes so that was i think we said
x equals negative two so following my
same scale
negative one negative two so here comes
my vertical asymptote
like so make sure you label that guy and
then i've got a horizontal asymptote as
well which we just determined was
y equals two so following my scale one
two draw my line all the way across
and then going in the other direction as
well okay so these are all of the bits
and pieces
how am i going to thread the needle so
everything fits together
well let's grab another color here and
let's look in the bottom right hand
corner because i've got more information
there i've got intercepts and stuff
right
i'm going to have to go from this part
of the graph here
up to here and then remember i'm
approaching this asymptote from
underneath
okay so i'm predicting it's something
like like this
right you can see i'm approaching that
asymptote from the bottom
and then to complete that part or that
branch of the graph you can see i'm now
going to approach the vertical asymptote
and i'm going to drop like a rock
you can try this out by putting in
values that are close to x equals
negative 2
like x equals negative 1.9 or x equals
negative 1.99
if you put those in which are sort of x
values around here
you're going to get y values that are
negative and very large
okay and the same way i'm going to think
about what happens on the other side
i've got to be somewhere over here now i
know i can't be around here because
there's no x-intercept there right that
was the first thing i found
so i'm going to have to be somewhere up
here because i've got these
two asymptotes that i've got to stay
between and i'm noticing that i'm going
to be above the asymptote because
like we saw here sorry i said yeah above
the asymptote
i had this value here of 2.005 from
memory so it's just above
okay so therefore i'm getting a shape a
bit like this
on the left and right uh over there okay
so this is my graph of my rational
function it's a bit weird and messy but
that's it you can see how i put together
my intercepts
my asymptotes and made a shape out of
that do i need a point for scale
i don't here because i have enough
intercepts that tell me this is
unambiguously
at y equals 2x minus 1 on
x plus 2. okay